[Música]
es hora de hablar de economía en France
24 por ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido
vamos a iniciar hablando del fondo
monetario internacional porque hoy
brindó su previsión de crecimiento
económico para Estados Unidos bueno el
organismo asegura que la ralentización
de esa economía podría provocar un leve
repunte del desempleo el próximo año el
fmi dice que el pib en Estados Unidos
cerrará este año en uno coma siete por
ciento por encima del 1,6% que habían
previsto Antes aunque luego disminuirá
al 1% el próximo año la directora del
fmi cristalina georgeva también habló
sobre las negociaciones del techo de la
deuda de Estados Unidos dijo que ese
país debería Elevar o suspender el
límite de inmediato ya que esta tardanza
en el resultado podría provocar provocar
riesgos sistemáticos escuchemos
si nos encontramos en un territorio en
el que no se encuentra una resolución y
Estados Unidos tiene que recortar el
gasto y al final llega A mediados de mes
la cuestión del servicio de la deuda de
Estados Unidos se hace muy real Entonces
estamos en territorio desconocido
bueno Y a propósito del techo de la
deuda hoy se extendió el plazo que había
anticipado el tesoro de Estados Unidos
hoy también el presidente Joe biden dijo
que está muy optimista que se podría
llegar a un acuerdo pero este optimismo
se lo hemos visto ya durante un tiempo
desde que ingresó en esa administración
bueno la nueva fecha Valentina es el 5
de junio próximo eso es 4 días más
extendidos que la fecha que habían dado
anteriormente lo dijo la secretaria del
tesoro en el momento en que el congreso
se toma un descanso por este largo fin
de semana del día de los caídos y
también aumenta las tensiones sobre si
se va a alcanzar o no
tiempo un acuerdo entre la casa blanca y
los republicanos el anuncio de yelen da
cierto respiro el presidente demócrata
Joe biden y el presidente republicano de
la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy para lograr al fin un acuerdo
la agencia de calificación Fish puso en
modo vigilancia una serie de valores que
están relacionados con el gobierno de
Estados Unidos ante una posible rebaja
de la calificación crediticia Jorge
Reino Unido cambiamos de tema nos
atravesamos el Atlántico porque el Reino
Unido podría entrar en recesión el
próximo año Así lo dijo el Primer
Ministro británico la alta inflación ahí
empuja a los tipos de interés a más del
5% probablemente para finales de este
año la doctrina económica dicta que a
mayor inflación los tipos de interés
deben subir con el fin de desacelerar la
economía para encontrar ese equilibrio
entre la oferta y la demanda que permita
de alguna forma bajar los precios la
inflación anual de Reino Unido cayó
hasta el 8,7% en abril menos de lo
esperado los especialistas los mercados
financieros también apuestan a que el
Banco Central suba su tipo de interés de
referencia al 5,5% desde el actual
4,5% para este año bueno venimos ahora a
la región en Cuba se preparan para una
inflación más alta el ministro de
economía de La Isla Alejandro Gil
reconoció que la inflación es el
problema económico más complejo Que
enfrenta su país según el funcionario la
inflación superará el 40% en 2023 los
precios de La Isla aumentaron 70% anual
en 2021 y un 40% en el 2022 según las
cifras oficiales pero varios analistas
creen que habría llegado a los tres
dígitos La Isla vive su peor crisis
económica en tres décadas con escasez de
alimento también de medicinas constantes
apagones y desde hace ya dos meses
desabastecimiento de combustible
escuchemos que si el ministro de
economía los precios han crecido como
promedio en los últimos 12 meses un 45%
pero los alimentos
cuando usted lo separa tiene un
crecimiento de más de un 70%
Jorge usted bajo presión qué tan
creativo se considera de 1 a 10 creo que
en las crisis uno se vuelve súper
creativo
mientras continúa la emergencia por la
erupción del volcán Popocatépetl algunos
locales están comerciando sus cenizas
Así es en exactamente en Atlixco en el
estado de Puebla varios artesanos
locales comenzaron a vender las cenizas
del volcán en pequeños frascos de
cristal como un recuerdo de la erupción
todo empezó como una broma que se
materializó en esta venta de artesanías
las cenizas las venden en pequeños
frascos con precios que oscilan entre
uno o dos dólares y bueno es parte de la
creatividad de los mexicanos en estos
momentos de crisis escuchemos
a guardar la ceniza para venderla
entonces pues se trata de que en ese
tiempo que está un poco pues complicada
la situación tengamos un ratito de
alegría no no pretendemos nada más
También estamos como muy conscientes del
peligro que representa vivir en la
cercanías del volcán Jorge Pues a usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica nosotros vamos con una semana
en el mundo mi compañero mi compañera
Rosa Pérez más deu los acompaña